after being arrested the failed former
president Donald Trump drove right to
the airport and flew directly back to
Florida there was an event promoted that
was scheduled for 8 15 PM Eastern last
night where Donald Trump was expected
and believed to speak about the arrest
and potentially it would even be a press
conference where he would take questions
he did not take any questions and Donald
Trump's brains seemed to disintegrate
during the event instead of talking
about yesterday's arrest the charges
against him and his defense he attacked
both the judge and the prosecutor and
kind of ran through his generic list of
grievances seemingly focusing on other
crimes he may have committed very very
strange event so let's start with a
claim that Donald Trump makes that
because he was President any documents
he takes from the White House are by
sort of like automatically Declassified
that's not how it works but again Trump
seems to be focusing on other crimes he
may be arrested for rather than the
crime for which he was arrested
yesterday to give up
but isn't that real obstruction
that's obstruction as President also
you'll notice Trump breathing in a very
strange way just sniffing the entire
thing everything every detail about this
speech was bizarre the right to
declassify documents and the process is
automatic
if I take them with me it's automatic
Declassified
Biden was vice president
he had absolutely no right to declassify
as vice president
he doesn't come under the non-criminal
presidential records act he comes under
the very criminal Federal records act
unfortunately for him but it's not going
to matter because they don't follow the
law which has very severe penalties so
first of all it is not automatic that if
a president just stuffs some documents
into his pants and then leaves that they
are Declassified secondly this was not
why Donald Trump was arrested yesterday
this is a completely different potential
set of charges remember we've got the
georgia-fulton County investigation
that's not what Trump is talking about
you then have the investigation related
to the search warrant served on
Mar-A-Lago that is what Trump is talking
about but those are different possible
crimes rather than the ones for which
Trump was actually arrested yesterday
Trump then attacking the judge saying
the judge hates Trump and the the family
hates Trump the judge's wife and the
judge's kids that every everybody just
hates Trump numbers
not the same place that I know not the
same place that you know
and this is where we are right now I
have a trump-hating judge
with a trump-hating wife and family
whose daughter worked for Kamala Harris
and now receives money from the Biden
Harris campaign and a lot of it
okay
Trump knows exactly what he's doing here
Trump is signaling Trump is spotlighting
Trump is putting a Target on the judge
and the judge's family and it's not like
we don't have evidence that Trump
supporters are willing to become violent
we know that they are I mean of course
there's January 6th you can also go back
further and there was the guy with the I
think it was pipe bombs who was arrested
and what year was it 2017 2018. we know
that there are people in Trump's cult
that will do violence and so when Trump
starts targeting I mean the judge's wife
why is the judge's wife even in Trump's
mouth why why is why is the words the
judge's daughter why is that coming out
of Trump's mouth he knows what he's
doing it's not only the judge that Trump
attacked he also attract attacked the
district attorney Alvin Bragg saying
actually they should arrest and indict
brag
the criminal is the district attorney
because he illegally leaked massive
amounts of grand jury information
for which he should be prosecuted yeah
or at a minimum he should resign there
you go uh of course there is no evidence
that Alvin Bragg has committed any
crimes whatsoever and as we've talked
about before it's Law and Order until
Law and Order is no longer convenient
and then it's just like indict my
political enemies no big deal not a not
a problem Trump then again continuing to
focus on his other possible crimes again
it you know his brain is mush
Trump says that they are the I I
actually struggle to understand this
Trump seems to be suggesting that the
search warrant served at Mar-A-Lago was
illegal and also that they they maybe
want to put Trump to death with the
Espionage it's really hard to follow
this reasonable search and seizure
but they did it anyway because our
justices
has become Lawless
they're using it now in addition to
everything else to win elections
apparently they're not looking at me
through the view of the non-criminal
presidential records act they came up
with a new one this is a new one
and they're looking at me through the
Espionage Act think of that how does
that sound of 1917 where the penalty
is death
even though that has absolutely nothing
to do with openly taking boxes of
documents and mostly clothing and other
things to my home
which President Obama has done the
bushes it was mostly closed guys the
fact that there were a couple hundred
classified documents that doesn't matter
it was mostly like shirts and Jimmy
Carter's done Ronald Reagan is done
everybody's done in fact
Hillary Clinton got rid of Clinton yeah
uh so anyway I guess he's saying the
search warrant was illegal and that they
are considering I guess or want to give
him the death penalty which is pretty
wacky stuff Trump also claims that he
doesn't need any banks because he has a
lot of cash which of course raises the
question of why Trump is desperately
asking for money if you have so much
money why are you asking your followers
you're a billionaire you're asking
people who make thirty two thousand
dollars a year to donate money to you
but they didn't lose a dollar with us
during this period of time
in fact the banks
we're talking about
made almost 200 million dollars off
Donald Trump
and they like me very much
we never missed a payment never got a
default notice had a great relationship
with all of them sure I don't need Banks
they have a lot of cash a lot of cash
but he's desperately raising money
anywhere that he can CNN in a kind of
funny moment cut away from the speech
and was confused about why Trump isn't
talking about yesterday's arrest which
is sort of the most newsworthy thing
going on
our current occurs crashing and we're no
longer the former president speaking
tonight at Mar-A-Lago back here in New
York with the panel
um Alyssa I mean this is a reprise of uh
we're waiting for him to talk about what
happened today finally talked about a
little bit at the end there and now
we're cutting out of it uh I love I love
Anderson Cooper's confusion about what
that was but a reprise and pretty much
every grievance if you were a Republican
who cares about the Republican Party in
the future of the Republican party and
you are watching this tonight realizing
this man now may be more powerful in the
Republican party than he was yesterday
or at least a little bit more so anyway
CNN bravely cutting away but only about
90 seconds before the speech ended and
then lastly here is Trump just abruptly
wrapping up the speech and walking off
oh no did we lose this clip is this clip
glitchy this clips glitchier than
Trump's speech hold on here we go
with all of
all of that
and with a very dark cloud
over our Beloved Country yeah I have no
doubt nevertheless
that we will make America great again
thank you very much God bless you and
God bless America thank you very much
everybody thank you isn't that great he
spends 30 minutes attacking everyone and
talking about how the country is just
horrible and he wraps up by saying
despite all of the horrible things I've
spent the last 30 minutes talking about
and all the possible crimes I just uh
admitted to things are going to be just
great I'm running and vote for me and
we're going to make America great again
so Trump's brain mayonnaise mayonnaise
or maybe a a bechamel I don't know what
it is but uh certainly something is a
little bit soft up there
um and it was just as crazy earlier in
New York City I want to talk about that
next
the weather is about to start warming up
and that often means sweating and
chafing and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great EXP experience with sheath
underwear I know you will too head on
over to sheathunderwear.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman for 20 off the link
is down below